thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis i'm denise valdez the countdown
is on to 2022 and thousands already
making their way to las vegas to ring in
the new year that means back up on the
roadways and crowds at the airport las
vegas metro police and the nevada
national guard also gearing up to keep
everyone safe this new year's eve sasha
loftus joins us live from an already
crowded las vegas strip with the very
latest
yes denise and brian you can see the
strip is pretty packed here as everyone
is already heading down to ring in the
new year if you know anyone traveling to
or from the valley they should expect a
lot of delays today and tomorrow this
was the scene earlier on the roads the
rtc reported a 16 mile backup on the
i-15 near the nevada california state
line harry reid international airport
has also been very crowded all week as
hundreds of thousands head here to las
vegas to ring in that new year metro
police will be out in full force to
patrol the strip and the downtown area
about 2200 nevada national guardsmen
will also be on hand to make sure
everyone stays safe
we're talking to the people who are out
there making sure they're having a great
time we're not there strongly for
enforcement we're there to make sure
that it's just safe and so from a
preparation standpoint this is something
they do all the time and
it's just to shift
in all officials are preparing for about
300 thousand people to hit the las vegas
strip tomorrow night i did check flights
at harry reid international earlier
tonight a couple cancellations and
delays but in all everything seem to be
moving pretty smoothly if you are headed
out tomorrow night lyft and the nevada
coalition for zero fatalities are
offering ten dollars off on a select
number of drives just use the code
ridesmart 2022. reporting live tonight
sasha loftis live local now